six people are in the hospital after a
shooting on u.s 95. the highway has been
closed for hours from horizon to boulder
highway as authorities continue their
investigation
good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight at six o'clock i'm sasha
loftis this happened around 12 30 this
afternoon according to henderson police
the suspect is still on the run right
now traffic is backed up as many are
heading back from lake mead in willow
beach madison kimbrough joins us live
near wagon wheel and u.s 95 tonight with
the latest madison
take a look at this back up here it's
pretty severe but now cars are moving at
a pretty good pace
according to sunrise hospital six people
were transported to the emergency room
this afternoon but so far henderson
police have only confirmed one person
was shot on highway 95. while we were
driving southbound on highway 95 we saw
several police cars and motorcycles
stopped off the side of the road
henderson police say the suspect is
still on the run as you mentioned
horizon drive from pacific to highway 95
has since reopened but was shut down in
both directions creating a real traffic
nightmare those we spoke to say they
just want to get back home
she's trying to go back to las vegas and
i have a flight to catch which is at 10
10 luckily and i hope i make it it's
been over an hour to try and get three
miles and no we haven't talked to
anybody else just
trying to stay patient
cars here on wagon wheel are now moving
at a good pace after being bumper to
pumper for hours again sunrise hospital
confirming with us that six people from
the shooting earlier were taken to the
hospital if you are in this area please
take precaution as you can see there's
still a lot of traffic going on
reporting live in henderson madison
kimbrough live local now
and we have been tracking that back up
in the area all day as madison said
things are starting to move again this
is video from earlier in the afternoon
you can see there is still a backup in
the area and that backup has been
lasting for a few miles now taking a
look at current conditions things are
moving a little quicker now